when the IRA were murdering people in
England we didn't drop 2,000 bombs on
Belfast because the terorists were
living among civilians H rings a bell
where did hijab mention that oh yeah RAF
were to then go into Belfast and dis
flatten as the IDF and these guys want
to
do these are some of the drinks in my
fridge guys just some of them sub that
we drink along water and many other
things many fruits to pick from many
foods to eat from Subhan Allah what
about the people who are starving in
Gaza all around the world who do not
have food to eat how can we make these
drinks these foods go down our throat
knowing that they're starving I am
working with one charity for the food
project guys and they are a 100%
donation policy charity I know the
brothers who run the charity and I have
full trust in them ahamed hijab was
right all along Piers Morgan it took him
the death of 40,000 innocent people to
come to the realization that Israel and
the Unholy schoy scum dirt bag and none
of them give a damn about your
journalistic bias even though you was
fully bias against them but you just be
objective in your um news coverage and
they would wipe their hands with you
they don't want you to be objective they
want you to be fully biased and even
then they will not be happy with you
this is showing the true reality mammed
hijab gave you a hypothetical situation
which you said that you don't live
hypothetical situations but
hypothetically you did not mind being a
black lesbian why can't I identify as a
black
lesbian but for some OD reason you
didn't here's the footage and here is
how Pierce Morgan finally finally yes
had you know it's too not too late to
become a human being you know come back
to your uh senses and be like you know
what humanly this is wrong for me to
support here is let's have a little
recap of what hijab said to him and
let's say peers Morgan's take on the
matter now when is finally should we say
finally speaking out against him RAF
were to then go into Belfast and dis
flatten as the IDF and these guys want
to do if they want to flatten Belfast
with all the white people Council of
States living in there what would you
say about that they never ever went out
one day and committed the barbaric
Slaughter of 30 no no if they did if
they did sorry it's not no Muhammad they
his wife is not irrelevant they they
never did but if they did they would you
ac they have to FL way there were
outrages committed by by the LA Lawless
Parliament to my question is they never
came would you think it's accept they
never they believe they were figh
political and Military Target trying to
bring it closer to home you're trying to
compare apples and oranges no I'm not
yes you are let me ask a question a
Palestinian and Isis were taken out by
the way with me no no here's my you
didn't do this with the ambassad which
you gave the show to him I don't do
hypotheticals let's you don't do
hypothetical no let's deal with reality
okay let's deal with reality now there's
no hypothetical situations but in this
clip he didn't mind hypothetically being
a black lesbian you can see brother and
sister Subhan Allah yes here is here is
pi Morgan finally finally waking up to
Muhammad hijab example that he gave and
rightly so as you can see Muhammad hijab
tweet there he said that you know this
rings a bell this example he gave when
the IRA were murdering people in England
we didn't drop £2,000 bombs on Belfast
because the terrorists were living among
civilians H rings the bell where did
hijab mention that oh yeah he did you're
learning from the champ you're learning
these examples from the champ that's why
you don't even realize you are and guess
what the Unholy shimoli has said this
weirdo yes respectfully Pi Morgan you
keep telling us you've upheld Israel's
right to defend itself as if you're
doing us je some great favor we don't
need your permission to stay alive any
more than the British needed us needed
ours to defend themselves against Hitler
there you go they are never going to be
happy they are never going to be happy
with you peers you're just a tool that
they are using that zionists are using
they have a bigger objective and believe
me they do not care about anyone you're
going to see their dark dark face even
more but for us Muslims who are watching
this you need to understand something
Allah subh as Muslims we have the
objective moral High Ground why because
to us if any Islamic State was to do
what Israel is doing to any minority be
it Christian be it Jew be it Hindu
whoever it is for that matter we as
Muslims are morally consistent not
strategically consistent like Pierce
Morgan Pierce Morgan's ytic and his
tolerance levil when it's a when it's
Muslims being massacred yes it's great
but when it's a Muslim doing something
it's there's no tolerance he has zero
tolerance
alhamdulillah with this example not only
did he show that finally he realized to
himself he couldn't I mean there's
people still defended but at least
alhamdulillah he done a u-turn at least
and spoke out against it alhamdulillah
our religion teaches us that if you take
one innocent Soul life it's as if you
took the whole of humanity this how we
see it we we live by this as if killing
one person it's as if you've wiped the
whole of humanity it's like a genocide
that you're doing one human being unjust
the kingdom and it shows the moral High
Ground Islam has and you can see the
Western World they do not care about
anyone nobody when Ukraine war was going
what would they say this is a war this
kind of thing stuff happen in third
world countries this happened to them
they you they can get blown up Etc but
to the Muslims no in Rafa now there are
actual babies who have been beheaded by
bombs actual actual not
lies Piers Morgan still shame on you for
defending these monsters for all this
time and thank God that you have finally
come to the words of Muhammad hijab and
woken up to the disgusting reality of
these evil evil scums the whole world is
Gaza the whole world is Gaza you have
woken up everybody and not only is
Israel losing this war on the ground
against Hamas they are also losing this
intellectual War they are losing the
public opinion and the whole world is
woken up to they evil and Allah says in
the Quran they plan and Allah plans and
Allah is the best of planners those
martys of 40,000 people that were
massacred best believe their names are
going to be remembered and the whole
entire world is going to remember
Israel when it ends that apartheid state
when it's day comes and it ends the
government when it comes people are
going to remember the atrocities that
they did
they will be forgiven but they will
never be forgotten